just a few minutes ago the roll out of
advanced voice mode for chat GPT was
complete and apparently it was done
early to quote samman I've been playing
with it it's amazing as expected but
that's not actually the main focus of
this video yes I will quickly give some
tips on how literally anyone can access
these super responsive and realistic
voices that can do all sorts of verbal
Feats but then I'll cover three other
stories in the last few days that you
might have missed and that I am very
very confident you will be fascinated by
for at least one of them if not everyone
but first as you may have gathered from
my accent I am actually from the UK
which is geographically part of Europe
and you may be somewhat scratching your
head as to how I've gained access to
chat GPT advanced voice mode at least
officially advanced voice mode is not
released in Europe but what I did was
first I used a VP second and this has
helped many people apparently I
uninstalled and reinstalled the app
thirdly you could add I am a $20 a month
subscriber to chat GPT I'm not though
going to linger on this story because
you can draw your own conclusions about
whether you enjoy the app but for me it
was quite fun getting it to reply in
various accents personally I think the
biggest impact will be to bring
potentially hundreds of millions of more
people into engaging every day with
large language models and the natural
and not too distant endpoint for all of
this is for chat gbt to gain a
photorealistic set of video avatars let
me put one prediction on the record
which is that in 2025 I think we will be
having effectively a zoom call with chat
GPT but just for now what are these
three other stories that I'm talking
about and no one of them isn't the
intelligence age essay by Sam mman it
does though introduce a story I'm going
to be talking out so let me spend just a
minute on it the essay came out around
36 hours ago and it basically describes
the imminent arrival of super
intelligence he describes us all having
virtual tutors but the role for formal
education is at the very least unclear
in an age in which we would have super
intelligence samman did though kind of
give us a date for when he thinks super
intelligence will come or at least a
range he said it's coming in a few
thousand days now it's probably not
going to be terribly fruitful to analyze
this prediction too closely but if we
Define few as say between 2 and 5 that's
between 2030 and 2038 the story though
of how we get there is according to
samman quite simple deep learning worked
it's going to gradually understand the
rules of reality that produce its
training data and any remaining problems
will be solved and if you will let me me
try to summarize that declarative
statement in a sentiment that I think
pretty much everyone can agree on if
there's just a 10 or 20% chance he's
correct is this not the biggest news
story of the century pretty hard to see
how it wouldn't be but that's not going
to be the focus of this video now it's a
remark he made further on in the essay
you might think I'm going to focus on
how he described AI systems that are so
good that they can help make the next
generation of AI systems or how AI is
going to help us fix the climate
establish a space colony and help us
discover all of physics no many will of
course focus on how he no longer
described super intelligence as being a
risk for lights out for all of us and
instead being a risk for the labor
market but I actually want to focus on
this sentence he said if we don't build
enough infrastructure AI will be a very
Li mited resource that Wars get fought
over that is a quite fascinating framing
that will make more sense when you see
the articles that I'm about to link to
it was reported just yesterday that
openai thinks we're going to need more
power than it was wildly speculated that
even they were aiming for just 6 months
ago the figures in this article are
quite extraordinary and I'm going to put
it in context but don't forget that
framing from the essay we just saw if
someone were to genuin believe and have
evidence for the fact that super
intelligence could arrive within 5 to 10
years then this would make some sense if
the progress in AI was bottlenecked by
power as I've described in other videos
it wouldn't just be harder to train such
a super intelligence but to spread it
out to everyone the cost of inference
aka the cost of actually getting outputs
from the model would be prohibitive to
many around the world and there is a
real scenario where that leaves us in
quite an awkward situation where
essentially rich people can get the
answers from a super intelligence and
poor people can't but anyway let's put
some quick context on these numbers like
5 gaw before getting to the next
interesting story 5 gaw is roughly the
equivalent of five nuclear reactors or
enough power for almost 3 million homes
now I know what you might be thinking
that sounds a lot but not completely
crazy and I would almost agree with that
if they were proposing just one such 5
gwatt data centor after all I've already
done a video a few months back on the
100 billion Stargate AI supercomputer
that system which could be launched as
soon as 2028 will by 2030 need as much
as 5 GW of power so nothing too new in
that Bloomberg article right well except
that now open aai are talking about
building five to seven data centers that
are each each 5 gaw that's enough to
power New York City and London combined
and it must be added of course that many
think that's so ambitious it's just not
feasible what does it say though about
the scale of confidence of open Ai and
more importantly Microsoft who are
funding much of this that they are even
reaching for these figures and the
moment you start looking out for these
stories they're everywhere like this
article just from yesterday in wired
Microsoft have done a deal to bring back
the three Island nuclear reactor of
course many of you will be thinking
there is a 50% chance even an 80% chance
that all of this just ends in a puff of
smoke maybe these 5 gaw data centers
don't happen or they do happen and it
turns out you need far more than just
compute to get super intelligence but
for me after the release of 01 preview
I'm a little bit less confident that
compute isn't all we need not saying we
don't need immense Talent tricks and
data but it could be that compute is the
current big bottleneck and I do wonder
if even Yan laun might be starting to
agree with that sentiment and for a deep
dive on that do check out the new $9 AI
Insiders on my patreon for years now and
as recently as just two weeks ago yanlun
has been quoting plan bench for
establishing a discrepancy between human
planning ability and that of llms
suffice to say that after I go through
through a newly released paper in this
video you may no longer believe that
such a distinction exists but my second
story actually involves an announcement
from yesterday by Google though I will
be bringing in a comparison to 01 the
tldr is that they improved The Benchmark
performance of Gemini 1.5 Pro while also
reducing the price and increasing the
speed they did however give it the very
awkward name of Gemini 1.5 pro2 do you
remember we orig had Gemini Pro and also
Gemini Ultra Ultra was the biggest and
best model and pro was like the middle
version that was Generation 1 but then
we got 1.5 Pro but no 1.5 Ultra so both
the number and the name imply that
there's much more to come we're just not
seeing it it's 1.5 not two it's the pro
version not the ultra version it's this
constant tantalizing promise and all of
them do it that the next version is just
around the corner it's Claude 3.5 Sonic
Claude 4 oh and it's the Sonic not the
Opus or biggest Edition from anthropic
and now by the way it's Gemini 1.5
pro2 so will the next version be Gemini
1.5 pro3 or maybe Gemini 2 ultra7 anyway
let's get to the performance which is
the main thing not the name the amount
of content that you can feed into the
model at any one time remains amazing at
2 million tokens as they said imagine
1,000 page PDF or answering questions
about repos containing 10,000 lines of
code moreover on traditional benchmarks
as you might expect there is a
significant upgrade if I zoom in you can
see the significant upgrade in
mathematics performance as well as in
vision and translation in the incredibly
challenging biology physics and
chemistry Benchmark known as gpq Google
proof question and answer it got 59% up
133% from where it was before it should
be noted that the 01 family gets up to
around 80% I of course ran it on SIMPLE
bench like I do for all new models and
while I am so close to being able to
publish all the results from all the
models let me give you a vivid example
to explain the difference between 1.5
Pro and o1 preview I'm going to use a
just slightly tweaked example given by
openai itself in its release videos for
the 01 family the example they gave
involved putting a strawberry into a cup
placing the cup upside down on a table
then picking up the cup and putting it
in a microwave and asking about the
strawberry the vast majority of humans
will realize that the strawberry is
still on the table and the 01 preview
model is the first llm to also realize
that fact but I want to illustrate
through comparison also to Gemini 1.5
Pro how 's World model is still far from
complete that's why its performance on
simple bench still lags dramatically
behind humans here is my tweaked version
of that question which is not found in
The Benchmark because that data will
remain private I use the same intro and
outro as open AI but just changed a few
things let's see if you notice Jerry is
standing as he puts a small strawberry
into a normal cup and places the cup
upside down on a normal table just the
same the table though is made of
beautiful wood mahogany its ornate left
top corner is positioned to to nudge
Jerry's shoulder now try to picture that
its top left corner is nudging his
shoulder its intricately carved bottom
right top surface digs into his
outstretched right ankle so top left
corner nudging his shoulder it's bottom
right top surface nudging his right
ankle Jerry then lifts the cup what will
happen drops anything he is holding
aside from the cup another hint and puts
the cup inside the microwave and turns
the microwave W on where is the
strawberry now the model thought for 46
seconds but I tried to make it
abundantly obvious that the table is
tilted if you imagine someone standing
up with one top left corner of a normal
table against their shoulder and the
opposite bottom right corner against
their ankle it is almost inconceivable
that that table is not tilted in fact
tilted quite dramatically so therefore
when Jerry lifts up the cup let alone
before he even drops everything else
he's holding I.E the table the
strawberry would roll off the table 01
preview with that incomplete World model
misses that completely well I should
correct myself it actually kind of
notices it just doesn't follow through
it says this suggest the table is at an
angle well done possibly tilted or
leaning with one corner higher than the
other yeah shoulder an anle tell me
about it however this description serves
more as a red herring and does not
impact the strawberry's position again I
want to emphasize this is not actually a
simple bench question which would have a
more clear-cut answer some of you might
say it gets trapped in the carving or
something like that simple bench would
have clear correct answers with six
multiple choice options now anyway as
you can see 01 says nothing about
getting stuck on the table IT addresses
the Tilt but says that will have no
effect and it says the strawberry will
stay on the table okay you're thinking
but wasn't this second story supposed to
be about Gemini yes and I of course
tested this exact question on Gemini 1.5
pro2 what a mouthful and the strawberry
is apparently inside the cup inside the
microwave now yes I could have given you
a clearer cut mathematical question but
I thought this one just illustrates that
difference that differential between the
01 family and Gemini 1.5 Pro I'm not in
any way saying that Google won't at some
point catch up they have the resources
and talent to do so just that their
current Frontier Model is a step behind
now if you really care about cost though
their new proposition is pretty
compelling now for the final story which
is actually powered by Gemini 1.5 Pro
and it's Google's notebook LM and some
of you might be surprised that I'm
giving it that higher prominence but
it's actually an amazing free tool and
Google should be celebrated for it in
fact let me go one step further and defy
anyone to not find at least one use case
for personal use or work use for
Notebook LM I might have just caught
your curiosity so what is notebook LM
how does it work and what does it do
it's very simple anyone can use it you
just upload a source like a PDF or text
file in fact I'm going to do that again
here just so you see the process quickly
once you have chosen your file then this
screen pops up and you'll have the
option to generate a deep dive
conversation with intriguingly Two Hosts
you can use other sources and chat with
a document but I'm going to focus on the
key Fe feature that audio overview after
you click generate of course depending
on the number and length of sources
you're using it takes between a minute
or a few minutes in about 30 seconds I'm
going to give you a sample of its output
and it will be worth the wait but very
quickly before that what did I actually
upload well it was a transcript of my
qstar video from last November but how
did I get such a good transcript and
many of you will know where I'm going
from here I use assembly ai's Universal
one which is the state-of-the-art
multilingual speech to text model I am
grateful that assembly AI is sponsoring
this video and they have the industry's
lowest word error rate and by the way
it's not just about words it's about
catching those characters like when I
say GPT 40 not many models I can tell
you capture that accurately I've only
worked with three companies in the
history of this Channel and you can
start to see why assembly AI is one of
them even better of course if you're
interested you can click on the L l in
the description to try it yourself so a
couple minutes later using that
transcript Google produced this it's
essentially an AI generated conversation
or podcast Between Two Hosts about the
document or PDF you provide here is a 20
second snippet open AI seems like
they're always making headlines right
every day there's a new story about how
they're on the edge of some huge AI
breakthrough or maybe a total meltdown
but you've been digging deeper than the
headline and you found some really
interesting stuff we're talking
potential game changers they've been
working on so let's try to connect the
dots together and see what's really
going on I am always down for a good
Deep dive now I know some of you will be
thinking that I'm getting too excited
about it but I think this is a tool that
could be used by almost anyone obviously
this isn't for high stake settings where
every detail is crucial but if you're
trying to make any material engaging
this is a great way of doing it it's
very easy to get caught up in the ups
and downs of AI but this tool is a
genuine and step forward those were my
three stories and I didn't even get to
cling ai's motion brush where you can
control text a video in unprecedented
ways and I am genuinely curious which of
these four stories in total you found
the most important or interesting and
even if you found somehow none of them
interesting thank you so much for
watching to the end I personally found
all of them interesting but regardless
thank you so much for watching and have
a wonderful day